the setting may seem idyllic but the
valley of al-lati is filled with fear
for this is no man's land in ethiopia's
civil war
and the people who live here have had to
suffer
we were taken to the battlefield by
members of a local militia
fields and mountain pastures contested
by the ethiopian military and fighters
from the restive region of tigray
and local farmers and their families
have been stuck in the middle
the junta did this he says the name
given here to tigre's rulers the tplf
great
it began as a battle for power
but it's led to all-out war in tigre and
here in the region of amhara
and human rights violations have been
committed on both sides say civil rights
groups
between
they told us 40 villagers were killed in
the last few days of august the majority
too old to flee
ahmed saeed says he buried nine using
fox holes dug by the soldiers although
hyenas had eaten their flesh
the tplf deny such allegations and have
called for an independent investigation
amid the fear and insecurity thousands
have taken up arms in amhara joining
local militia called the fano
and we were invited to inspect this unit
in a town called jirana
[Applause]
their commander told us he's personally
killed 13 members of the tplf
there are thousands of
army troops nearby
why don't you just leave it to them
yet again
yeah a rundown teachers college offers a
sanctuary of sorts for those who've been
forced from their homes
but there's only room for a few of an
estimated 2.5 million displaced by this
conflict do you want to show us
okay
a young mother told us she was
struggling the only thing the
authorities have provided is a concrete
floor
is it hard to live here
but um
too much
too high
i don't know
[Music]
foreign but it may be worse in tigre
where the un says millions are living in
famine-like conditions
[Music]
and with a massive ethiopian offensive
now reported in amhara the humanitarian
front will only deteriorate john sparks
sky news in desi ethiopia